[Applaudissements]
et
maintenant la petite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Tonino c'est moi qui suis sa petite son
nana son nana son anamiteux je suis vive
je suis
charmante comme un petit oiseaux qu'il
chante il m'appelle sa petite bourgeoise
sa t quii sa t ki Satan quiinoise
d'autres lui font les dou yeux mais
c'est moi qui l'aime le mieux soir en
cause de T chose avant de se mettre au
pieu j'apprends la
géographie de la Chine et la mancherie
les
frontières les rivières le fleuve Jaune
et Leleu bleu il y a même l'amour
c'estécrieux carose l'Empire t mes lieux
c'est moi qui suis sa petite son ananas
son ananas son anamite je suis vive je
suis
chalement comme un petit oiseau qu'il
chante il m'appelle la petite bourgeoise
Satan kiki Satan kiki Satan quinoise
d'autres lui font les de Dieu
mais c'est
moi
qui
le
[Musique]
mieux